good evening ladies and gentlemen I'm
Alan Kahn president of Barnes Noble
publishing we at Barnes & Noble are
thrilled to be publishing the new
humanists science at the edge a book
filled with with cutting edge idea we
have dead mics up here this little one
working now I'm Alan Kahn from Barnes &
Noble we at Barnes & Noble are thrilled
to be publishing the new humanists
science at the edge a book filled with
cutting edge ideas from many brilliant
scientists and empirical thinkers two of
them are here tonight Daniel C Dennett
and Marvin Minsky they will discuss how
the universe designs itself but before I
begin before we begin I'd like to
introduce John Brockman the editor of
the new humanists as well as being a
well-known author and editor mr.
Brockman is president of the edge
foundation and the founder president and
editor of edge a website that serves as
an intellect isn't in this as a as an
intellectual forum for science and other
thinkers edge which has more than a
hundred thousand visitors and
participants features some of the best
minds of today including such well-known
intellectuals as Jared Diamond Steven
Pinker Jared linear reycarts while and
our two speakers tonight edge captures
online the continuing conversations of
these prominent members of the edge
community the new humanists was derived
from this preeminent group of
intellectuals and scientists they
illustrate Brockman's theory that we are
entering a third culture one defined by
coming together by the coming together
of the humanities and science Brockman
calls for a new energy between these two
areas which are often viewed as separate
or incompatible
tonight's discussion will illustrate
Brockman's theory and the lively spirit
of edge Barnes and Noble is proud to be
associated with edge and a book that
highlights some of the best scientific
thinkers of the 21st century here to
inter introduce our panelists is John
Bachman a key to this book is the idea
that the central metaphor about the
central metaphor of our time is
computation it's about the computer the
models we create by using computers and
the act of computing or computation it
it's running across all the disciplines
and I realized having seminars of groups
that included Marvin and Dan that will
have biologists artificial intelligence
experts physicists and what connects
them all is the notion of computation in
terms of that field about ten years ago
and I put together the book the third
culture I introduced Marvin as the
leading light of AI that is artificial
intelligence he sees the brain as a
myriad of structures scientists who
liked Minsky take a strong AI view
believed that a computer model of the
brain will be able to explain what we
know of the brains cognitive abilities
Minsky identifies consciousness with
high-level abstract thought and believes
in principle that machines can do
everything that a conscious human being
could do for Dan Dennett I said that Dan
is interested in consciousness his views
similar to Minsky's is as a high-level
abstract thinking he's known as the
leading proponent of the computational
model of mind in
in that regard of people like Pinker
have followed on and developed this
along with in his class with
philosophers such as darn Cyril who
maintained that the most important
aspects of consciousness intentionally
intentionality and subjective quality
can never be computed he's the
philosopher of choice of the AI
community in this most recent work he
has turned to what he calls Darwin's
dangerous idea
he's squarely in the Darwinian camp of
George C Williams of Richard Dawkins and
he has mustered with great energy a
serious critique of the scientific ideas
of Stephen Jay Gould
it was the critique of Gould all hundred
pages that ended a lot of people's
relationships with Gould when someone
like tenet writes 100 pages about you
you have to stop what you're doing and
spent three years to respond now that
that is over it's been about ten years
Gould unfortunately as long with us
Dennett is writing a new book called
breaking the spell in which he's gonna
relax a bit after Gould and take on a
god Marvin when I was doing this third
culture book we had asked everybody in
the book to comment on the other people
and Marvin's comment about Dan was well
he's our greatest philosopher since
Russell
six months later I sent the galleys and
he said I wrote that what I meant is the
greatest philosopher that understands
what we're doing so I will turn it over
to address the topic of how the universe
designs itself I've asked each of these
gentlemen to speak for 15 minutes
uninterrupted ask each other
some questions and then we'll open it to
the floor
Marvin is just back from Japan wait for
someone to ask a question what would you
like to talk about I just like impassive
to say that I don't think the universe
exists I'll just say a few bits and then
I want to see how Dennett reacts a lot
of people feel that there are some
important questions that science can't
answer and that's why they resort to
religion and one of the questions well
they're there various questions that are
very hard to answer like where the world
come from and or in a more naive way who
made the world because everything you
see in civilization was made by somebody
nobody made rocks and so what do you do
about those exceptions and you imagine
some super being from the x-files or
x-men or something who can make whole
worlds and that gives people of warm
fuzzy feeling which but
and of course the idea of God is
wonderful because it's the answer to all
questions you can't understand and in
this book that I'm finishing but you can
read chapter 4 on my web page it's a
discussion of consciousness and it's
quite harmonious with what Dennett has
said because I used the same idea that
there isn't any one thing that's
consciousness there's a lot of stuff and
in particular different parts of your
lighter making different stories and
weaving them together and there's all
sorts of negotiations but on a larger
scale I think the word consciousness is
a very convenient word to have because
it's the name for all of the things your
mind does that you don't have any idea
about and it's useful to have such words
and God is the name of the answer to all
the questions about the world that you
don't have a good answer to so let me
just say or what you can do about that
and the first thing is to notice that
there's something wrong with who made
the world religious people have trained
themselves not to worry about that
because you say who made the world and
they say God and you say who made God
and they say that's rude or God made
itself or it was always there or
whatever isn't it stunning that that's
not considered an objection to the God
theory
that it's whereas in science it would be
regarded as well there's something wrong
with your theory but there's let's be a
little more serious if you look at the
question who made everything or why does
the universe exist there's something
wrong with the word exist because what
does it mean to say this alleged spring
water exists I mean the eggs do you see
these big trucks driving by every day
full of Evian or whatever it is spring
water and you count the number of trucks
and guess how many people drink it and
figure out what size pipe is coming out
of some poor little hill somewhere
anyway to say something exists says that
it's in the universe to say the universe
exists is a little bothersome sort of
problem that Bertrand Russell Dan's
predecessor worried about and decided
that you had to be very careful about
statements where a thing is part of
itself or a subset of itself or
something so it doesn't mean anything to
say the universe exists because that
would be to say the universe is inside
itself it's alright to say the universe
is itself but it doesn't seem right to
say that it's part of itself so how do
you get out of that and it seems to me
you shouldn't be asking what made
everything you should be saying what
could this word exist mean that we're so
quickly extending from very little
things like the water is in the bottle
to the bottle is in the universe what's
the universe in and I think the best
answer is that that's probably
meaningless there are probably a lot of
possible universes and there's nothing
special about any of them this is just
what would happen if you had a big
computer and dropped a program into it
and it simulates all this but suppose
somebody wrote that program then that
world would exist in the sense that this
program says
we do suppose they didn't write the
program suppose you never loaded into
computer it would still be the same
possible world suppose you didn't even
write the program well somebody else
might have written it what difference
does it make if somebody's written it or
even thought of it well I'm not joking
it seems to me that this is this is a
possible logical system or unlogical
system or whatever and then what you
have to do is ask is there anything
special about it and obviously there is
this is one that could have people in it
and what's more a since Darwin you can't
just drop people into a world you have
to evolve them they have to come
somewhere the universe has to make them
as John hints and what does that mean
well that universe had better have some
conservation laws like energy suppose
you didn't have in others why is the
world the way it is physicists are
nervous about this kind of argument
called the anthropic argument and I'm
not sure why they're so nervous it's a
great argument if the world didn't have
conservation laws like the ones Newton
discovered energy is conserved momentum
and angular momentum are conserved as
long as they don't bump into anything
what would happen if you didn't have
that law or if that if the universe
didn't have that constraint well every
now and then something would start
generating energy and maybe make little
parts that do the same thing and in five
minutes the entire galaxy would blow up
some physicists say how come the
universe is such that the Einstein
coefficient is very close to one and the
answer is if the universe were expanding
much faster or contracting much faster
of course we might have been in it once
but we wouldn't be now and so lots of
things about the universe have to be
that way or else things wouldn't be
stable for long
to evolve which as far as we know
usually takes three point half a billion
years we only have one example of it and
that's about how long it took then it
took it's only 500 million years since
we were fish so there was about three
billion years of nothing much happening
there was a moment when was the Cambrian
explosion yeah right and in that there
was a book by Stephen Gould that I hated
it was because it was so romantic was
called wonderful life he made little
references to Jimmy Stewart and things
in it Steve had a wonderfully homey way
of combining the familiar with the
ridiculous and the big mystery to him
was how come just at this moment in
evolution did suddenly animals develop
literally millions of kinds of forms you
take this this bunch of shale which is
only ten million or so years wide it's
not much and there's hardly any kind of
animal at first and then there are all
these forms and snails and little things
practically insect like stuff and Gould
makes up some theory that Darwinism
isn't really a very good theory because
it would suggest that things happen
slowly and steadily where's things
happen very suddenly but what happened
that's when animals got little nervous
systems and what happens when an animal
gets a nervous system well it can crawl
around and you can evolve mechanisms but
what happens when that little brain has
any kind of learning at all something
very dramatic happens which was
understood by what was Baldwin's name
the great evolutionism around around
1900 yeah I can tell what his first name
was but but this is the Baldwin effect
and Steve ghouls didn't seem to know
about it here's what happens suppose you
have something like a crab and this crab
has evolved exactly to eat a certain
kind of seaweed by detecting it and
going like that what would happen if
there was a mutation and the poor crabs
arms went like that would starve to
death and and so animals had to be very
rigid before they could learn but if the
animal was like this and by accident had
happened to do this he could remember it
and though the point is that once you've
got a nervous system that could learn a
deformity was not fatal and that's
exactly the time of the Cambrian
explosion so the creatures could mutate
that but still survive and there was
something that looks like an explosion
and that Darwin has not explained this
and of course he has so I'll stop and
see if we can get into an argument
Marvin lives for arguments and we I've
known for about thirty years and and you
know if if you don't start arguing with
him right away those things things more
and more outrageous until finally you
realize that you're supposed to resist
but today he started right off by saying
the universe doesn't exist now he's
already played his trump card I don't
know how you how if you're not gonna
balk at that how are we doing to Bach
but I'm going to resist the temptation
for the moment because I want to first
of all I want to follow up on a point he
just made about the Cambrian explosion
yes Steve Gould said it was a it was a
sort of an embarrassment to classical
Darwinism because it was this
embarrassment of riches this fabulous
time of creativity when all these new
life forms came into existence very fast
and then most of them disappeared very
fast strange
architecture's body plans that that
didn't survive at all
well he wasn't very imaginative about
what might explain it and I think Marvin
has put his finger on it but there's a
book that came out justice last year by
the Oxford zoologist Andrew Parker which
really is I highly recommend if you want
a very good read on this topic it's
called in the blink of an eye
and Parker's thesis is that five hundred
and thirty five hundred forty million
years ago that's when for reasons he's
not very clear about the oceans became
transparent and light for some chemical
reason because now you've had a medium
in which you could see if only you had
eyes and this is one and this is one
eyes evolved they they evolved as soon
as a medium of transparency evolved all
life was in the water at that point and
there was locomotion but it was sort of
blind groping locomotion there were
worms and things like that but they
couldn't see where they were going they
were just sort of bumping around and as
soon as the water became transparent the
vision evolved and once vision evolves
the great game of hide-and-seek begins
now you can see at a distance now you
have an epistemic horizon which is
getting farther away you don't have to
wait till you bump into something once
you don't have to bump into something
once you have radar in effect once you
have distal perception it's a whole new
ballgame
suddenly the Predators can see the prey
and the prey can see the Predators and
the tremendous the the prodigious
creative energy of evolution was
unleashed by the simply that all you had
to do is render the ocean more
transparent and we're off to the races
it's an arms race now
what's nice about Andrew Parker's theory
is that it's testable and there's many
predictions that it makes and it may not
in the end be quite right but it
completely against the lie to the idea
that this sudden explosion of creativity
by evolution is any sort of an anomaly
or any sort of an embarrassment to
evolution if it's an embarrassment at
all it's an embarrassment of riches
there's there are many many
possibilities to explain why the
Cambrian explosion happened and as I
like to say in the consciousness wars of
which I am a part I am I am a very
tolerant of all sorts of craziness that
goes on in the world of consciousness
from search am I my sort of MAOIs motto
is let a thousand flowers bloom but then
remember that 999 of them are going to
wilt there's an awful lot of junk out
there and let's get it behind us as soon
as we can and then we'll get to the to
the good theories and I think that's
what happened in the Cambrian explosion
for itself
now I'm really sorry that Lee Smolin
isn't here because actually John invited
us all to submit a title for this and I
was the one that came up with how the
universe designs itself and I really
thought of this is an occasion when
Marvin and I were going to provoke Lee
because that's in a way more his idea
than ours but it's a very interesting
idea and let me just explain to you what
what how I conceived of this topic and I
will do my best to do some rough justice
to some of these ideas as some of you
know one of my big things for oh my gosh
30 years and more has been what I call
the three stances the intentional stance
the design stance in the physical stance
but I want to talk about the design
stance
if you look around the world you see a
lot of things that seem to be designed
obviously the artifacts in front of us
the watch the microphone even this
plastic glass these have all been
designed by intelligent designers to
serve various purposes but so does
everything in the living world seem to
be designed and exquisitely designed
that's the famous argument from design
and until Darwin came along it was a
magnificent argument it really was
impressive these things can't be
accidents as Paley had said and in fact
I have hypothesized that this idea that
there's no design without a designer is
perhaps older than our species how could
that be well before there was Homo
sapiens sapiens that's us
there was Homo habilis you know the the
handyman made tools we've been making
tools for since before there was
homeless sapiens we've been making stone
axes and things like and I think perhaps
as long as hominids have been making
tools that has seen just crashing li
obvious that it takes a big fancy thing
to design and make a simpler thing you
never see a pot making a Potter you
never see a horseshoe making a
blacksmith and so all these wonderful
big fancy things making things which are
considerably less wonderful sort of the
trickle-down theory of design
and I think that was just obvious to the
world until Darwin and when Darwin put
forward the theory of natural selection
all of a sudden an alternative became
available and in fact one of one of his
earliest critics
thank goodness for this man an otherwise
anonymous man named Robert Beverly
Mackenzie wrote a very heated and
outraged negative review of the Origin
of Species and there's a passage in it
which I just love to quote and I I
actually wrote it out I printed it out
so that I could get it right it's I love
this partly for the outrage let me just
read what what Robert Beverly Mackenzie
had to say about Darwin's dangerous idea
we fed in the theory with which we have
to deal absolute ignorance and he
capitalizes that a I absolute ignorance
is the artificer so that we may
enunciate as the fundamental principle
of the whole system that in order to
make a perfect and beautiful machine it
is not requisite to know how to make it
this proposition will be found on
careful examination to express in
condensed form the essential purport of
the theory and to express in a few words
all mr. Darwin's meaning who by a
strange inversion of reasoning seems to
think absolute ignorance fully qualified
to take the place of absolute wisdom in
all the achievements of creative skill
bingo yes that is exactly what Darwin is
saying absolute ignorance can take the
place of absolute wisdom in all the
achievements of creative skill that's
the strange inversion of reasoning that
Darwin introduces to us and it goes down
hard this is this is really a
revolutionary turning upside down
of the way we've thought about creation
and design since before we were even
Homo sapiens and what we've seen in the
time just since Darwin is a series of
sort of retreats on the part of
thoughtful people trying to deal with
this this strange idea that you can have
design manifest design in the biosphere
without an intelligent designer ASA gray
who was a contemporary of Darwin's and
professor at Harvard famously said well
you see Grodd isn't the the designer of
each and every critter you know all
creatures great and small God designs
the system that then churns out the
bunch of them he that he he's he chooses
the the physics if you like and the
fundamental biological principles and
then just let's turn the crank and let's
let's all the rest of the design happen
he had a lovely phrase for it he said
designed by wholesale is even better
than designed by retail so so god the
wholesale designer is the is the
successor to God the the individual
handicraft er but then people began to
think well what about these laws of
nature that God so cleverly devised so
that evolution could happen here's where
Lee Smolin really comes in because
because Lee and other cosmologists and
physicists have suggested that these
exquisitely tuned constants of physics
that Marvin was talking about this these
uncannily precisely chosen
values of the variables that permit life
to permit our universe to be one in
which life can evolve because carbon
atoms are sticky enough to be a sort of
great glue you know the fundamental glue
that holds things together in fancy
mechanisms maybe those aren't so much
constant it's just locally constant
maybe there's a whole lot of universes
out there and we just happen to be in
one of course we couldn't be in any
other where all the laws are just right
if you're in it if you're in a if you're
in a universe that has life it's gonna
have to have laws that are life friendly
that make it possible this is the
anthropic principle now so then God gets
demoted from law giver to not even to
law chooser because now we suppose well
the part of the universe that we're in
has these laws but it's no no no
accident that that should be so we don't
need God to choose the laws because the
other parts of the universe where there
are other laws they also exist or may
exist for all we know so we so God is
demoted again so what's gods man well
he's sort of a a master of ceremonies I
guess or maybe you know our Father who
placed air guitar or something like that
so we've watched this somewhat graceful
and somewhat graceless retreat where God
has given less and less to do to the
point where it's no longer such a
mystery that he should be omnipotent if
you don't have any job then it's not so
hard to be omnipotent now these ideas
may amuse some of us but they they
strike terror and repugnance in the
minds of many people who want the
traditional top-down view of an
intelligent designer to prevail and it's
fascinating to see how many how even the
most resourceful and wily scientific
speculators can be drawn back again and
again to the idea that maybe there's
some way where we can we can save the
idea of an intelligent designer after
all well in a way I think we should all
be agnostic about that maybe there is
but by the time we've established that
it is going to be so different from the
original imagined creator that if those
who are religious want to say something
like well we told you so we'll say well
if you have to say that go ahead but of
course it isn't it's so remote from
anything you ever imagined or could have
imagined using your traditional point of
view that that it doesn't really count
now it's Lea were here if I may go on
for just another minute or so playing
the lead role what's fascinating about
about Lea Lee's work is that he's found
some ways to take seriously I mean very
seriously as a physicist the idea that
evolution can actually apply below the
biological level to the level of in
effect universes or sub universes
themselves that you can have an
evolution of universes so that the
universe can indeed design itself if he
was here he would he would give you a
version of that I'm going to give you
the joke version of
this story I like about the the young
aspiring tenor the operatic tenor who
finally gets his his debut opera let's
say it's Atlas Scala where they take
their opera very seriously and at the
end of the first act he does his area
and this roaring applause standing
applause it goes on and on and on he
buys some boughs and boughs and they
keep yelling encore so he does it again
and at the end of it the second time
they plot again and and he goes off and
he comes out and takes a bow he goes off
and comes up things about they're still
applauding so he sings to the third time
he goes off and they're still fighting
and he's of course delirious with joy
but he's getting worn out at this point
he comes Isis no no thank you thank you
thank you no no more and somebody jumps
up and says no we're gonna make you do
it again until you get it right and that
in effect is the Lee Smolin theory about
universes - we're gonna do it again
until we get it right that that that
whole universes can in effect be rough
draft semi rough drafts penultimate
drafts and so forth that there can be a
process of evolution of universes and at
first when you encounter this idea if
you're like me or sort of cross-eyed and
you think this is just too extravagant
there can't be any way of taking this
seriously from the point of view of
science and that's an important point
you know I'm a philosopher I'm not a
scientist and one thing I know is that
imagination is cheap we philosophers are
love to invent imaginary universe as
possible worlds and think about what's
possible and what's not possible but
we're stuck with rather crude tools in a
certain way and that beyond brute
logical possibility which is a very weak
notion we're not very good and we
we don't have any way of keeping
ourselves honest many people thought of
evolution before Darwin he was not the
first person to think of evolution by
natural selection but he was the one who
figured out how to bring the empirical
demands into the picture in such a way
that you had to take the idea seriously
now Lee Smolin has done something which
I would not before he wrote thought
possible and that is come up with the
physics that at least requires you to
take seriously the idea which is not
that hard to imagine that there could be
an evolution of universes themselves
that there could be an evolution of the
very laws of physics that makes
biological evolution possible that
doesn't mean that he's shown it's
possible but he has shown that we have
to take it seriously and that's where
you can't do that if you're just the
philosopher that's one of the
limitations of our trade is that we
don't have the leverage to sort out the
imaginable and to those things that are
imaginable and also that should be taken
seriously for that you need you need to
make the game harder you need to do some
serious work so that people have to say
yeah okay that that's a possibility we
have to take seriously I probably said
enough now from Marvin to come in and
contradict some of them said
maybe we should
I can't think of anything I don't know
these theory and I know the who's the
guy who makes the Gaia theory love in
which the earth evolves so love Locke's
theory is quite popular but it doesn't
it's hard to make it work because if
there's only one planet he argues that
as the history of the planet proceeds
the earth learns to stabilize is
temperature and that their various
mechanisms that get selected so that
finally we get a really stable planet of
course all of us are interested to know
if were alone in the universe and if not
why aren't we get an email from from the
rest of it and one possibility is that
these this delicate collection of
parameters like the temperature has to
be between water freezing and boiling
stuff like that
has to remain those constants have to
remain or non constants have to remain
bound for billions of years because it
took 500 and it's about six six hundred
million years since the first
multicellular creatures arrived plants
and animals both but if the earth made a
mistake there's no way it could learn
from that mistake because there's only
one of it so I'm not sure what Lee's
idea is a single universe can't have
selection and it's hard to have
evolution unless there's some selection
on the other what's interesting is that
he histories proposes that again to be
crude about it that black holes are in
effect birth options but or do they make
copies of things they main copies with
variation that's the whole that's a
little point ok and yeah I'm sorry Lee
isn't here I can species we should just
maybe drop that topic because I don't
want to do injustice to Lisa she is
there but I want to I want to suggest
something about Lee's perspective and
what Martin was just saying about the
need for a long period of constancy for
evolution to take place well even a
billion years is just a just a fraction
of it's not even a it's an infinitesimal
fraction of infinity so that you could
have a stretch of a billion years of
pattern is not in itself improbable it's
important for people to realize since
you could take it personally they don't
know this particular situation we have
here is only good for another three or
four billion years because that's when
the Sun becomes a red giant so we've
really got to get out of here
pretty soon and what's interesting is
that people laugh when you say that
because it's ridiculous to try to
survive isn't it I think there is
something wrong with people that they're
not very much concerned with the future
they want to live a normal life and I've
interviewed a lot of people as a result
of writing an article on longevity in
the Scientific American and in a typical
audience if you ask people if you want
would they like to live 500 years they
all say no almost all and you say why
and they say well because you'd be very
creaky and you have arthritis and I say
well but suppose you could stay at your
own age or half your present age and
they still don't want to and now you ask
why and they say it's boring however if
you talk to an audience of scientists
which is what I mostly do it's
completely different they all have
problems that they can't solve now and
they could use a couple of hundred years
and so it's interesting that that
culture the second culture is wild about
the idea of immortality whereas the
first culture really doesn't have any
goals it's trying to live a comfortable
life it goes to football games and
wastes at synapses on stuff like that
and generally things are pretty boring
so that's a problem about the two
cultures and
we should we should be doing something
open it up before mother empties the
hall there is a microphone right in the
central Highland members are to come to
the microphone here if you'd like to ask
a question we do have time for a few
questions if you'd like to come up and
ask you a question from the microphones
so that both our panel members and
everybody can hear thank you
the CIA we have great microphones we
have one brave question are coming to
the market I got up quickly anticipating
a rush and discover out with the only
one coming up so it just relax the idea
that we're part of a large ensemble of
universes has been getting a lot of
currency lately I read a couple of
interesting papers by Max tegmark that
that have had some very interesting
implications one of the things that he
notes is actually that the idea that
there's an ensemble of universes is
simpler than the idea that there's one
because there's less you know there's
less algorithmic information density and
ensemble in fact close to none
whereas a single one ironically has has
far more complexity to it I I was
wondering you know if you know I mean if
any of you well dr. muskie was
mentioning the idea that you know that
perhaps there you know that the question
of whether or not the universe exists is
not an interesting one perhaps you know
as tegmark actually has suggested
elsewhere that you know that any
mathematically consistent set of rules
that could give rise to life is going to
be internally experienced yeah I was
wondering if you might want to expand
upon that
no I think there's there's no way you
could tell whether you're in one that
exists or not and so it seems like you
shouldn't spend any of your 30,000 days
worrying about that there must be 30
thousand questions that I don't yet know
how to assess max tegmark s-- ideas or
david deutsches ideas or lease moments
ideas to name three and there's and and
Seth Lloyd and others as many but but I
know this much they're really
interesting ideas that are have more
hooks on them than some of the old
philosophical chestnuts if you just ask
yourself the question why is there
something rather than nothing you're
just sort of gobsmacked there's nothing
you can do with that question you don't
know what the background is you don't
know anything about what would count as
an answer now in one sense that's by my
lights that's what philosophy is
philosophy is what you're doing when you
don't know what the right questions are
and you don't know what yet what would
count is a good answer but one of the
reasons that I is a philosopher I'm
interested in these proposals by the
physicists is that they they have shape
they have structure they have a detail
there's something you can do with them
maybe some of them are completely crazy
in the end but we're gonna be able to
figure that out
they're not just waffling ideas they're
ideas that that have implications that
can be very carefully and rigorously
developed and that's the reason that I'm
interested in
because I didn't bring it with me
there's a nice quote by a philosopher
named John Searle who says that you know
150 years ago the latest thing was the
Telegraph and people said oh maybe
that's how animals work the nerves are
like telegraph wires and then there was
the telephone and radio and he says
artificial intelligence or the
computational idea of psychology is just
the latest fad and it will pass too
because non philosophers always adopt
the latest technological breakthrough as
their worldview I just wanted to say
that and it's related to what Dan said
that I can't well when the students come
in September and they say I say what do
you want to study and they say I want to
study computer science I usually say
well that's just a fad in the sense that
if you study computer science rather
than mathematics for four years then by
your senior year you'll have to start
all over because computers sciences
obeys Moore's law and the amount of it
doubles every four years so it's just no
point in trying to keep up with that but
seriously I think computer science is a
new thing it has nothing to do with
computers those are just things for
computing what computer science did
starting around 1950 was to take up
where mathematics had run flat how do
you describe very complicated systems
well mathematics is great for describing
the system that depends on a few axioms
or laws geometry has about ten acts he
was a beautiful thing called group
theory that has for maybe it's five
and you can explore them in great depth
but if there's 50 assumptions
mathematics is sort of helpless and if
one of the assumptions says there's a
switch where it can either go this way
or that way things are pretty bad so
what happened starting around 1950 was
the development of new ways of
describing things in terms of procedures
that people had barely imagined and then
you had the computers to see what the
consequences of these assumptions would
be even if you couldn't figure them out
so I think that in some sense this is
the last fad but it will change into
unrecognizably more powerful forms and
the idea of psychology being a
collection what happens if you have a
whole collection of highly evolved
computers interacting in highly ways is
probably the answer to a lot of
questions that had no answers at all
before this question is to start start
with Dan this is in regard to your book
freedom evolve which I read a couple of
months ago and I very much enjoyed and
can recommend now you know you're you
start off the book by positing you know
free will compared to determinism and in
a way it's a false opposition because we
can look at free will freedom is
something that clearly evolves from
rocks to simple organisms to birds to
humans something has changed in that
progression and we have to honor it and
consider it and think about the
implications legal religious etcetera
but somewhere near the end of the book
you make a statement if I'm remembering
correctly where you say that still
doesn't get us past the the conundrum of
determinism because as you go from one
step let's say the mind is a hole down
to cognitive modules down to neurons
down to molecules down to atoms
determinism still holds but there's so
many levels of so much complexity that
we will never
be able to do the computation let's say
from the adam2 to the human mind and
therefore we don't have to worry about
it no no that's a reading that might be
invited but that's not what I meant
can you elaborate because because I see
I still got your point about freedom is
something that evolves and therefore we
but we can't we must throw out the whole
deterministic conundrum what I was
trying to argue was that freedom and
determinism are entirely compatible
determinism doesn't go away I mean who
cares for the determinism is true
actually because we can we can at Marvin
says a switch we can have a switch turn
determinism on turn determinism off make
it in deterministic nothing changes in
in at the levels that matter to us
you're not going to be better off if
you're living in an indeterminate ik
world than if you're living in a
deterministic world the whole
determinism in determinism at the level
of physics issue I argue is simply
orthogonal simply irrelevant to the
issues that really matter about freedom
what we want is to have free will that's
morally important there are I can define
varieties of free will which are of no
moral significance whatever and then I
can show that we either have them or
don't but who cares the kind of freewill
that we're interested in is the kind
that aisle astray by thinking about
cases where yeah I I invite you to think
of the worst thing you ever did and then
you think well you know could I have
done otherwise and and is my regret is
it is it rational or or am i some have
just involved in some absurd game and I
try to show why it can be rational why
it is rational to conceive of your life
in terms of free choices and it's not an
illusion
it's but you have to understand that
what free choices means and ought to
mean is not what the philosophical
tradition says it is does that help
well yeah because I do recall you you
would say that we have free will but
it's not the free will that most of us
thought we yeah that's right hello I
haven't read any of your books but I
thought it'd be kind of fun to take
God's side for just a little bit sure
and by means of kind of yo Wilson's
sociobiological interpretation of what
religions about you guys both seem to
suggest at least that religion is
something that the species kind of
adopted cuz we needed some quick answers
and we've been kind of hesitant to get
rid of because it explains things of
course Wilson's point is that religion
is actually a very successful adaptation
that the species made and it's been so
successful because it reinforces things
like altruism and the family and social
cohesion and so it actually is no big
problem well I'm seeing the words I'm
saying but he wrote them in human nature
you know the freshman knows yeah and
that it's you know been a very
successful idea well you know here's
another really successful idea evolute
on the evolutionary timescale if it's
sweet eat it the sweet tooth is is a
fine adaptation or was we've outgrown
that adaptation it is now not Fitness
enhancing at all in our hunter-gatherer
days the sweet tooth was a was a great
adaptation have it really helped us but
now it's the bane of our existence and
we're working very hard to figure out
how to overcome this natural deeply
ingrained love of sweet things and and
we're succeeding to some said
we understand the problem so it might be
true that our religious sweet tooth was
a great idea
for a long time and it might also be
true that it isn't a good idea anymore
it might be turning on us now the
fitness of an adaptation or the fitness
enhancing power of an adaptation is not
guaranteed to last forever and in fact
we often one of the great sources of
evidence about evolution is when we see
adaptations which have outlived their
usefulness and are now becoming
positively harmful it's a simply an open
question whether whether religion
whether the sort of cohesiveness of
religion is still good for us I like the
analogy with with what my my farmer
friends in Maine have told me they call
it a nurse crop when I replanted my hay
fields some years ago one of the local
farmers said well you want to put down
oats as a nurse crop when you plant the
Timothy the hay I said what do you mean
a nurse crop he said well you plant the
both seeds at once and the oats come up
first and they keep out the weeds and
they protect the Timothy until it can
grow up and the oats grow up first and
you can harvest the oats if you want or
you can just leave them there just sort
of a protective shield a nurse crop for
that for the Timothy and I think that
religion may well have been a sort of
cultural nurse crop I don't think we
need it anymore however valuable it may
have been in the early days of
civilization
question you'll be glad to know about
computation and I suppose that makes it
more dr. Minsky's province although I'm
not fussy there is no question that
access to computation is transforming
the sciences do you think that
scientists are asking different kinds of
questions because of that or are they
simply pursuing the questions they would
have asked with greater efficiency or in
greater depth or does it depend on what
kind of science they practice very broad
question
there certainly are specific ones that
when you see a complicated system
you used to expect to find that there
was a complicated source for it and one
of the things that became widely
understood since computer science was
that simple processes can generate
unlimited variety and so you get these
chaos theories and you're no longer need
to assume that there's anything random
in a system that looks random there
could just be a 30 bit shift register or
something like that so I don't can't
think of more general things to say but
we know about processes that we hadn't
imagined before I'm a little
uncomfortable about saying that because
in the 1920s there were people like
Ackerman and post in the 1930s who
understood chaos and even prior a and
the late
19th century knew that there would be
some day something like mathematics that
I would understand these things but it's
since nineteen fifty or sixty the idea
that complexity can appear where you
wouldn't have expected it before
incidentally the public has some idea
that quantum mechanics involves
uncertainty and that that the quantum
world is indeterminate and the
physicists have allowed that to go on
for a long time in the current pictures
of quantum mechanics the Schrodinger
equation is a continuous function and so
forth and for a long time nobody could
think of why packets of light would go
this way in that way apparently in
random and now there are theories about
that which don't have any randomness at
all so it's interesting that the public
still thinks things are random gentlemen
I think we just have time for one more
question
thank you
on the matter of design and designer
could both of you comment on what
perhaps was Einstein's views of that
problem or that conundrum and how come
what has happened to bring your ideas of
that to compare now I have a quick
answer to that which is looking on the
past
Einstein is famous for many interesting
accomplishments one is that he was
perhaps the most skillful politician of
the previous century he made lots of
remarks in public to the press and so
forth and he never made a mistake in his
strategy so he steers the way between
the atheists and the religious people so
skillfully I wish well I don't want to
do it anymore but I wish I had known how
to in the past so I don't I'm of course
was often quoted as saying that the dear
Lord is subtle but not malicious but he
also complained bitterly and often that
he didn't himself believe in any
personal god of any sort that was just a
metaphor he was very clear that that he
did not mean by that or any other
reference to God a personal God who
could actually be subtle or malicious
and of course George Williams the the
biologist John mentioned him earlier is
one of our one of our our leading
Darwinian and and George has famously
turned Einstein's famous quote upside
down and said that mother nature is
vicious of stupid
thank you all very much of tan Dennett's
latest book is in the store it's called
freedom evolves Marvin Minsky is now
nine years late delivering his book so
if you'd like to encourage them please
do so on the way out thank you